man i just saw this this ridiculous
thing that
that uh maz vidal said like colby
covington's not a draw
in any way like no way i would fight him
like i'm gonna be selling out
pay-per-views
he nobody wants and it was just like
okay you know yeah i i've said this a
million times
that i i'm so invested in
disliking colby covington that i just
absolutely want him to win
and win and win and win so that he'll
always be there
for me to dislike well i would
and i would say george does i don't
think george wants to fight colby
that's exactly what's going on if you're
going to be the bmf
if you're going to be the bmf and you're
going to say your game brad and you'll
fight anyone
then you fight anyone then why why are
you talking about how big of a draw it
is
because you're supposed to not care
you're supposed to be the bmf
you're supposed to say i don't really
give a [ __ ] show up on
july 12th and then we'll be there right
now supposed to make excuses that
they're not i'm not a big enough draw
it's ridiculous
right and uh it's absolutely a [ __ ]
massive draw for sure yeah yeah colby's
almost got that
jake paul knit where it's like you want
to see him lose right
yeah dude you know what pisses me off
expensive sunglasses
because you're going to lose him anyway
so never pay more than 10 bucks for a
pair that's why i buy mine at the gas
station
except they don't ever have the kind
that i'm very particular about i like my
style
right so i made my own these are stevo
sunglasses
and they're only 9.99 at stevo.com and
we got them back in stock
so don't be squinting in the sun getting
wrinkles
go to stevo.com and make your summer fly
with some stevo's sunglasses